a lot of times i had a friend uh we were
auditioning for this thing and he came
in
looking so ridiculous and he was doing
this really stereotypical
interpretation and i said man what are
you doing
and he said yeah yeah you know and i
said well why are you doing that way i
mean why are you kind of shocking and
doing whatever the hell are you doing
and he said you know that's what they
want and so that's what who wants to say
that's what they want
and that that's it they want us to be
that way and so the assumption is that i
better go ahead and do that and i i just
i never assumed playing winston that i
had to be subservient
that's sad that it makes me feel makes
me feel kind of bad that he would
think that but he was probably had
rightfully so the role
unless i've been on uh auditions where
people
in fact uh one of my actor friends i
came in
and it was part of it was a part of a
cook really
but i came in i had a t-shirt on my arms
he said man you better go you better
comfortably cut your arms up
and i said why is it anyone that you
want to scream with your arms like that
man you know that
brother come in because you're gonna be
and i'm like uh
who says this but it's all these
assumptions and actually you help
perpetuate
this stereotype unknowingly because
you are doing what you think they want
you to do
and until somebody comes along and kind
of go why can't i produce it
why can't i direct it or why wow that um
it changes that's more powerful that's
pretty powerful i grew up believing
oh what we should say they'll never see
an interracial relationship on
tv they'll never see you'll never see
that because
and for a long time you do i mean for a
long time it's like oh well
it's not going to happen um and now i'm
lilly tomlin's boyfriend
that's amazing but you had a different
perspective ernie
you that that's a rare that you had a
certain innate like
ability to come up with these roles or
have a personality and you didn't like
say oh this is the pimp roll or this is
the the cop and i'll be like this and
i'll be
like some you had a perspective on this
character which
i i obviously gave you a lot i knew guys
who considered themselves pimps
but i didn't see them as pimps i knew
him as my friend um
you know um german you know
jeremy's a film but jeremy i know jeremy
i know his mother i know he's jeremy
you know he he's a person he's not a
pimp
and a lot of actors felt like you want
me to play the pimp no
i want you to play jeremy winston is
winston i don't want winston to be the
black guy
right and i've done shows where even the
directors would kind of
not so suddenly say uh ernie um could
you you know just
uh do it a little more you know that
that thing
you do and i said what thing well yeah
you know you know the giant i mean just
just make him a little more
jiver driver mini jiver
yeah you know i was like he's he's here
come on man do that thing you do
and was like i don't do that thing i
don't want to tell you oh my god
dude i could just see him this guy is
he's a guy who's trying to feed his
family and he may have to do these
things but he's not
you know we we see we think we know
everything about him but you
that's not who this man is and so if i
play him
to be this then then then he's not a
person so i had to
even though i did one show it's called
too close for comfort oh i used to love
that show
yeah tonight so i played a part where
um they accidentally knocked a hole in
the wall
and so to get it repaired uh there's a
prison system where they
the former prisoners uh you can hire
them
to help you know so they they call the
hotline
and they hire me and my uh ex
felony partner is a white guy and so
we uh walk in the house and they show us
a hole in the in the wall
and so my line is holding my helia
now i don't even know what the hell it
means i'll be honest with you i'm like
i don't understand and uh he said no no
just just see it
and so i would say holy man don't don't
say it with energy and he wants me to do
this holy
hell yeah and i like this is crazy so i
talked to ted knight and
i said tim do you understand this and
ted is like no what the hell does that
mean doesn't make any sense to me and
all the other actors are like
no you don't just say that don't see it
and then finally the producer said
listen
when you auditioned you said it and you
said it perfectly
and i hired you for that night you say
holy hell yeah or i'll get somebody
else who will now i need the job
so i walked in and i said holy my hell
yeah it i mean
you